STEREN GIANNINI: Hi,
I'm Steren Giannini.
Welcome to Cloud Run--
What's New?
So a year ago, we launched,
publicly, Cloud Run.
In this session,
I'm going to go--
I'm going to go over
the few improvements
that we've released since then.
This session will be
structured in three dimensions.
We'll see how Cloud Run is now
even more enterprise-ready,
how it is more
developer-friendly,
and the how it gives
you more flexibility.
But first, I want to recap.
What is Cloud Run?
So Cloud Run allows
you to run containers
on a fully managed environment.
We can call that serverless.
Its main characteristics
are that it auto-scales,
there is no
infrastructure to manage,
and it allows you to go fast.
It makes you productive.
So as I said, you can deploy
containers in seconds.
And thanks to that, you can
use any language, any library
you want because of containers.
We spent a lot of
time delivering
an enhanced developer experience
so that we make you productive
when using Cloud Run.
A few nice things is that
when you deploy to Cloud Run,
you get, out-of-the-box,
an automatic HTTPS endpoint
for your service.
And you can attach your own
custom domain very easily.
Cloud Run is portable--
first, because it accepts the
container standard as an input,
but also because it
is based on Knative,
an open source project that
allows you to run serverless
workloads anywhere.
And Cloud Run is also
available for Anthos,
allowing you to run
the same Cloud Run
workloads in your own cluster,
be it on Google Cloud,
on other clouds, or on prem.
And finally, Cloud
Run is pay per use.
Your literally only pay
for when your containers
are processing requests
rounded up to 100 milliseconds.
So with that, let's dive in.
Let's see how Cloud Run is now
even more enterprise-ready.
So first, when we launched a
year ago, we launched to beta.
And today we are
generally available.
Of course, that comes
with all of the goodness
of a generally available product
of GCP in terms of support
and in terms of
service-level agreement.
Cloud Run has 99.95%
availability SLA.
Then we have been
very hard at work
to turn on Cloud Run in
many different regions
all over the world.
So what you see on that
map are, the green dots
are where Cloud Run
is available today.
And the blue dots
is where we plan
to operate Cloud Run
by the end of the year.
So as you've seen, we
now cover all continents.
And we are hard at work turning
up even more regions very soon.
Then, one of the
key features that we
added that was
requested by many of you
was the ability to access your
resources that are in your VPC,
in your Virtual Private Cloud.
So for example, thanks to
serverless VPC connectors,
Cloud Run can now connect
to Cloud Memorystore Redis,
or Memcache, or simply connect
to a private IP of a Compute
Engine VM, for example.
Next, we-- you know, when we
raised Cloud Run, you could--
anytime you were deploying a
new revision of a Cloud Run
service, this revision was
starting to serve traffic
as fast as possible to 100%.
Well, we all know
that's not really
how we should deliver
software, right?
So what we added
is the capability
to control the rollout
of few revisions,
or even to roll back
to a previous revision.
So let's see an example of
what we call a blue/green
deployment.
So let's assume we
are in a revision.
That will be called blue.
And we want to deploy to
something called green.
So the first step
is to, of course,
deploy that new revision.
So let's assume I want to deploy
a new image of my container.
So I would use a regular
command you would know,
except that this time, I'm going
to say, do not serve traffic.
And I'm going to give it a tag--
green for this example.
Of course, I'm showing you
this through the command line,
but you can shooting exactly
the same from the Cloud Console.
Once I've done that, this
revision that was created
is not going to serve traffic.
But I, as a developer, or
my team, can give it a try,
can invoke it under a very
specific URL that contains
the tag that we just added.
So once I've validated that this
new revision is ready to go,
is behaving correctly, then
it's time to send traffic
to it gradually.
So I will start--
I will start small.
I will start by sending
1% of the traffic
to that new revision.
So in that case, I'm using
the update traffic command.
And I'm going to say,
send 1% to the tag green.
And the system will know that
the tag green is attached
to a specific
revision and that 1%
of the incoming external traffic
should go to that new revision.
From my end, what
I should do now
is take a look at my
monitoring dashboard, my logs,
filter by this revision
name, and double-check
that everything's fine.
Once I confirm that everything
is good to continue,
then it's time to send more
traffic to that revision.
So I'm going to send
10%, wait a little bit,
double-check everything is fine,
send 50%, wait a little bit,
check everything is
fine, and finally, send
100% of the incoming traffic
to that new revision.
And by the way, at
Google, we mostly
do all virtual rollouts
over four days,
making sure that everything
is healthy between each step.
Once I've done that,
I'm good to go.
This new revision is serving
all of the incoming traffic.
And I consider this just
a new current revision.
If at any point in time
during the rollout,
or at any point in
time, I can roll back
to a previous revision.
To do so, it's one click
in the user interface
or one command with GCloud,
which is an update--
I update the traffic,
but this time,
to a specific revision name.
And I send 100% of
the traffic to it,
which means I'm going to
roll back to that revision.
So hopefully, that can help
you mostly safely release
your container and your software
by giving you more control
and allowing you to traffic
split between revisions.
All right, then we added support
for Google Cloud Artifact
Registry.
So Artifact Registry is the
evolution of Google Cloud
Container Registry.
And the benefits
of it is that you
can have content or registries
in very specific regions
in the regions you want.
So that's even better
for data localities
so that you can store your
containers wherever you want.
You can even use your
own encryption keys
to encrypt those
containers in the registry.
Cloud Artifact Registry
has a free tier,
which is always good.
And you can have per repository
access control using Cloud IAM.
So in the example on the
right, what I'm doing
is that I'm deploying to Cloud
Run from Artifact Registry
where my registry is actually
from Europe north 1, a very
specific region in Europe.
OK, next, in the
enterprise-ready category,
we added support for Google
Cloud load balancing.
So what that helps
you do, for example,
is that if you deploy the same
Cloud Run service in three
different regions, you
can add, on top of them,
Google Cloud load
balancer and expose
a global endpoint that
will route requests
to the closest region in
order to reduce latency,
but also to be resilient
to original outages in case
something goes bad in
a Google Cloud region.
So let's see an example.
Here, somebody
from San Francisco
connects to my global endpoint.
Well, Google Cloud load
balancer will run that request
to my cloud and service,
which is in the US.
But now if somebody
from Paris connects
to that same global endpoint,
then Google Cloud load balancer
will send the request
to Europe west 1.
So you see how you can build
global services with increased
availability and performances
on top of multiple Cloud Run
services.
But that's not all.
Google Cloud load balancer
allows you to use Cloud CDN.
So now, by using Google Cloud
load balancer and Cloud CDN
on top of Cloud Run,
you can, for example,
reduce the load on your
Cloud Run service or increase
performance of your
official service.
So let's see this example.
The very first request comes in.
This one is not cached, because
nobody has seen it before.
This one will reach
the Cloud Run service.
Cloud Run can respond with a
special response header, which
is cache-control,
and saying, I want
you to cache this
request for 300 seconds.
Good.
Next time a client
asks the same,
Cloud CDN will be able
to return the request
without even it needing to
reach your Cloud Run service.
So you see how by
caching some request,
you can drastically reduce
the load on your service
and performance.
So that's not all.
Google Cloud load balancer
integration gives us even more.
Identity aware
proxy is something
that allows you
to add, basically,
a login screen on top of
your Cloud Run service.
And this login screen can
enable you to grant access
to only certain users
inside your organization,
for example, your employee,
for an internal application--
so once again, identity
aware proxy via Google
Cloud load balancing
on top of Cloud Run.
And very similarly, you
can use Cloud Armor thanks
to Google Cloud load balancing.
So Cloud Armor is a web
application firewall.
It will help you in case of
a denial of service attack.
And it will help you accept only
some IPs from certain IP ranges
or geographies.
So in this example on
the right, I am only
accepting IPs from a range,
and the others get rejected.
So the rejected ones don't even
reach my Cloud Run service.
This is all handled by Cloud
Armor via Google Cloud load
balancer.
So hopefully we
are convincing you
how Cloud Run is,
even more than before,
enterprise-ready with all of
those very important features
that you have been
asking us to deliver.
Now let's see how Cloud Run is
even more developer-friendly.
So first, we've
heard your feedback.
And thank you for sharing
that you like Cloud Run.
We measured, via some
Cloud Console surveys,
that most of you are very
satisfied with Cloud Run.
And so we are
pleased to hear that.
And this is one of the highest
satisfaction score that we've
seen for Google Cloud.
So we are very proud of this.
But we haven't stopped there.
We are keeping delivering many
developer-focused features
to make you even
more productive.
And one of them is the ability
to deploy from a YAML fine.
So if you want to store the
configuration of your Cloud Run
services in your version
control system in config files,
well, you can.
And actually, because Cloud Run
implements the Knative serving
API, this file is
exactly a Knative
serving resource descriptor.
So this is what--
with that, you can achieve
what some people called GitOps,
which is, you use Git
as your source of truth
when it comes to your
resource configuration.
So we've added a new
command to G Cloud called
gcloud run services replace.
And that takes a YAML
file of your service.
Next, we've worked with
the Cloud Code team
to bring Cloud Run integration
inside the Cloud Code IDE
plugins for IntelliJ
and Visual Studio Code.
So this plugin will help
you bootstrap new Clout Run
apps with sample apps.
It will help you manage your
services and your revisions,
see their properties.
It will help you build your
source code into containers
and deploy them to Cloud Run.
And my favorite, it will help
you run your Cloud Run services
locally inside a
containerized environment that
looks a lot what you would have
if you deployed to Cloud Run.
Next, Google Cloud has released
Google Cloud buildpacks.
So buildpacks are
basically recipes
to create containers in very--
in a set of very
popular languages.
In our case, the Google Cloud
buildpacks support Go, Node.js,
Python, Java, and .NET.
Thanks to buildpacks,
you don't need
to worry about writing
Dockerfiles anymore.
If you see the
example on the right,
my source code doesn't
contain any Dockerfile.
And I'm able to build
it with Cloud Build,
using the --pack command, into
a container that I can then
deploy to Cloud Run.
Buildpacks are-- those
buildpacks are open source.
And buildpacks are
a CNCF open standard
that are used by many vendors.
So we are very proud
to have them today
to help you build
the containers.
Next is that when you
deploy to Cloud Run,
and when you build your
container from a Git
repository, we now capture
the context of this container
and display that right
inside the user interface.
So if you see on
that slide, you see
how, in addition to the
container image URL,
we give you a link to
the build that was used
to create that container
as well as a link
to the GitHub repository at
this specific commit for you
to troubleshoot
in case something
is wrong with that
particular container.
And in a similar
fashion, we are also
helping you embrace
the best practices
of continuous deployment.
So right now, from the
Cloud Run user interface,
you can, in a few
clicks, configure
a continuous deployment pipeline
for your Cloud Run service.
So let's take a look.
Right now I'm creating
a new service.
And I'm going to-- instead of
picking a specific container
that I already built, I'm going
to select a Git repository.
So when I click this, it asks
me to authenticate with GitHub
if GitHub is where your
Git repositories are.
Then I can select one
of my repositories.
I validate the
build configuration,
giving it a location of my
Dockerfile and my branch.
I hit Save.
And then Cloud Run will
create the Cloud Run service
as well as create a Cloud Build
trigger that will automatically
watch this repository
for new commits,
and when they are pushed
to this repository,
will automatically build
and deploy to Cloud Run.
So in that case, we
trigger the first build.
And your service is now
serving with the code that
was in your Git repository.
Over time, we even
show you the history
of the builds right
inside the Cloud Run user
interface for convenience.
But that's not all what we've
delivered for developers.
I'm very excited
to say that we are
launching new ways to
trigger your Cloud Run
services via events.
So basically, you can now
trigger Cloud Run services
when events are emitted from
other Google Cloud resources.
So this is all based
on Cloud audit logs.
So you might know that GCP
resources, anytime they are
changed, they emit audit logs.
So very easily,
what you can do now
is you can trigger
your Cloud Run
service any time one of your
GCP resources is mutated.
And the events that you receive
to your Cloud Run service
are delivered in an
open standard again,
the cloud events open standard,
which was a CNCF project.
So I'm also very
excited to say that we
are launching Cloud workflows.
So Cloud workflows allow you
to orchestrate your serverless
task with the rich and
declarative programming model.
For example, you want to process
events with multiple Cloud Run
services, you can
chain API calls.
You can automate
infrastructure management.
You can implement retry
polices very easily
thanks to Cloud workflows.
So in this example on the right,
what I'm doing, very simply,
is, every day, I want to stop
all of my developer machines.
So to do that, every
day at 6:00 PM,
one Cloud Run service returns
me a list of all of the dev VMs.
Another one extracts
their statuses.
And for each VM, I
extract the status.
If it is running, I stop it.
And then I email
the owner of this VM
to make sure that tomorrow,
they don't forget to stop them.
So you see how you can
build complex workflows
by bringing together very
simple serverless pieces.
So that's it.
That's how we have made
Cloud Run even more
developer-friendly
over the last month.
And we are not stopping
there, of course.
Now let's see how we've--
we've heard your feedback.
And we've been removing
some of the limits
that Cloud Run had
at the beginning
by giving you more flexibility.
So first, we heard you.
You want more RAM.
You want more CPUs.
So you can now go
up to 4 gigabytes
of memory and four vCPUs.
On a very similar
fashion, in the past,
you were limited to 15 minutes
of request processing time.
We are now extending
that to an hour.
So you can process things
up to one hour on Cloud Run.
Next, once again, we
are delivering something
that a lot of you
have been asking for.
Today, as I mentioned, Cloud
Run auto-scales, and notably,
scales down to 0.
So that's great.
But that means that when
there is no traffic,
and suddenly there is
traffic that comes in,
you have what we call a cold
start, which is the time
it takes to start--
to go from zero
container instances
to one continuing
instance or more.
And this usually depends a
lot on what your container is
doing at startup time.
With many instances,
you can say, hey,
I want a minimum of, for
example, two instances
always on at any point in time.
And when that's
the case, Cloud Run
will make sure that
your number of instances
never goes below this specific--
the number you specify.
So that's great for
improving performance,
notably when it
scales down to zero.
But the good news is that
those instances, when
they are not in
use, actually are
cheaper than active instances.
Another thing we've added
to help you better handle
the auto-scaling of Cloud
Run is that we are now
sending a signal before the
instance is shutting down.
So that gives you the
time, for example,
to close any open
database connection
or to send any data
that you might not
have sent in kept in memory.
By sending this
SIGTERM signal, you
have up to 10 seconds
of processing time
where you can do something
before the instance is
shut down.
We've also heard you.
We added support for gRPC.
So now, out of the box,
your Cloud Run service
can expose a gRPC server.
Nothing to configure,
just your code
has to start a gRPC
server that listens
on the same port as the one
we are sending regular HTTP
requests.
So gRPC on a service
infrastructure-- yes,
that's possible with Cloud Run.
And lastly, we've also
heard your feedback.
We added support for
server-side streaming.
So what that means is that you
can now stream your responses
back to the clients.
You are not limited
anymore by the response
size of 32 megabytes.
And the responses are
not buffered anymore.
That allows you to stream
HTTP and gRPC responses.
In the example on the
right, what I'm doing is
my small web server is
actually serving a video file
into the client.
And I'm using this
special header
transfer encoding chunked.
That means that the client
will be downloading the stream
of the bytes of this video.
So hopefully this
has been moving
some of the limits that were
initially part of Cloud Run.
And don't worry, we
are not stopping here.
We are keeping removing
those existing limits.
So hopefully, with this
talk, I convinced you
how Cloud Run is now, even more
than ever, enterprise-ready,
and even more than ever,
developer-friendly,
and by removing some
of its original limits,
gives you more flexibility.
We have been very hard
at work to deliver all
of these features last year.
And we are, of course,
not going to stop here.
I want to thank you for
attending this session
and we can't wait to
see the great thing is
you will build with Cloud Run.